(upbeat music)
- To stay ahead of the
field, Ford Performance
constantly develop their race cars.
Driver biometrics are
monitored second by second
ensuring peak physical performance.
Their next daring maneuver,
harnessing the power of the mind.
Ford are developing a
unique motorsport helmet
that reads the drivers brain activity.
Their team of engineers and
scientists have integrated
cutting edge technology
electroencephalography,
or EEG for short, into the helmet itself.
EEG uses electrodes to
record electrical charges
that signal activity in the brain.
The team can measure driver
focus in high pressure
situations to reveal crucial moments
of suboptimal performance.
The EEG electrodes lie within
the foam inside the helmet,
in contact with the scalp.
The brain data is then fed
out to external hardware.
Drivers gain insight into
how their brain performs while driving.
This unique, bespoke
information can improve
how they drive and in some
way, help them to win.